- Hi!
- Hey!
[Cross Talk]
- Do we look okay?
- Oh is that a devil Melissa?
[Cross Talk]
- We are the Neutz family.
- We've always been
known as a large family
and we're all so very close.
We're a strong family of faith.
- When we get together
it's 60 or 70 people
- I guess when I think about
my family, I just think
I'm one of the luckiest guys
in the world, I really do.
We're all very close.
[Singing Happy Birthday]
- We went from worrying
about our hands being clean
and what groceries we
needed to buy to not even
like a week and a half later
our mom's in the hospital.
We realized we were not gonna
to be able to be with our mom
[Melancholy piano music]
- I don't see how she was
able to raise eight children
with what we had and for
everybody to turn out pretty good
- She was devoted to the family,
you know we had an alcoholic father,
who unfortunately died an alcoholic.
But mom was very strong
and she kept us together as a family.
[Laughter]
- What do you think Keiko?
- [Laughs] She's so cute!
[Melancholy piano music]
- When she first went into the hospital
and we knew that we weren't
going to be able to visit her,
it just really gave everyone
a sense of hopelessness
and helplessness that we
wouldn't have anything
that we could do, even if we wanted to,
to hold her hand or to be with her.
Lacy figured out that we
could get a laptop to her.
- A nurse at the hospital
came and met me outside
and grabbed the laptop
and within about an hour
it was up in her room set up.
- Mom I think would have loved
that to be her last 24 hours,
- a party
- it was like a real party
- Say Happy New Year!
- Happy New Year!
- We even sent food and one
of the families got to watch
her enjoy her Japanese dinner and
you know, we even kind of thought
maybe she was gonna come around,
you know watching her there.
- On Sunday, the doctors had let us know
that she was most likely
going to be passing soon.
They were going to go ahead
and minister what they call
comfort drugs,
so each of the brothers
and sisters had gathered up
each of their family members
and then we each were able to
get on the House Party app
and spend time with her
as a family unit.
- I would say mom it's Tommy,
and she would go, Tommy!
I said I love you mom and she
responded back, I love you
and I cannot tell you
what that meant to me.
They had her on an oxygen
mask, they had a mask
that just covered her face
and oxygen was blowing through that mask.
When they did pull the mask off,
the nurse was holding her
hand, within less than a minute
she said she's gone.
When they went to go remove that mask,
was when the nurses
gathered around her room
outside her door and the
other nurses held her hand.
So it was a pretty touching
moment for all of us.
- The hardest part of this for me is not
to be able to be with you all
because we're such a great
support for each other.
- It feels a little surreal,
I know that she was in the hospital
and I know that she's not here,
but it also seems like kind
of was it just a dream?
Like did it really happen?
Some of it just seems not real
because you didn't see her
and we didn't all get together.
- The whole situation
really just makes you feel
like you're being robbed,
of not being able to hug
your loved ones, you know,
or be with them, or talk about,
share stories about our
grandmother together.
You just never imagine in a
million years that this is how
it would play out and this
is how it would happen.